hello today we're looking at
neutralization reactions which is a
topic in c1 a neutralization reaction is
a reaction between an acid and a base to
give salt and water acids of a pH of
less than seven bases have a pH of more
than seven and salt and water have a pH
of seven because they're neutral so
let's see how this stuff works now a
couple of examples of bases one would be
a metal oxide now this metal could be
any different metal it could be
aluminium it could be iron there's loads
of different options for what this can
be our acids we need to know about three
different types of acid we need to know
about nitric acid hydrochloric acid and
sulfuric acid so um we also need to know
about metal hydroxides which are also
bases again this metal could can change
but will always have a hydroxide if it's
a metal hydroxide so let's have a look
at a specific example now like I said
there's three types of acid we need to
know I think we'll start off just by
having a look at nitric acid and the
reason why I've come to this color
scheme is so they match the pH scale now
let's say I had nitric acid and mixed it
with let's go for sodium oxide okay now
this here is a base metal oxide now I
know that I'm going to get salt and
water but I can't just write this goes
to salt because I need to know the
specific name of the salt I need to be
able to name this now there's a really
nice rule for this and we need to
remember these so whenever we have a
night nitric acid we know that the salt
form is going to be a type of nitrate
whenever we have hydrochloric acid we
know the type of salt form is going to
be a chloride and whenever we have
sulfuric acid we know the type of salt
formed is going to be a sulphate so if
we know these and learn these oops sorry
on these then we'll be really confident
with naming ourselves okay so just put
these here to help us with this here now
I know that the salt as well is going to
have sodium in it
cliff sodium isn't going to magically
disappear it's just going to form name
of part of the salt so this salt is
going to be called sodium and because of
using nitric acid it's going to be
called a nitrate as a result this salt
is called sodium nitrate and notice as
well I always get my water my water is
just going to be like this just water
okay so let's have a look at another
example using a metal hydroxide this
time so why don't we try let's pick a
different matter why don't we have
magnesium hydroxide will also pick a
different acid so the acid will pick
this time why don't we go for sulfuric
acid
okay so again I follow the same rules as
before okay so myself uric acid and
magnesium hydroxide so I know that I'm
going to have magnesium it's going to be
a part of the name of the salt okay so
it's going to be called magnesium
something now because I'm using sulfuric
acid I know that I'm going to form a
sulfate as a result it's going to be
magnesium sulfate I'm just going to
write it underneath here my medium
sulfate plus water so we could see it
follows the same rules every time now
the only time it gets slightly more
complicated is when we have a metal
carbonate as well okay so metal
carbonates also can neutralize acids so
metal carbonates now let's have a look
at an example of this because with metal
carbonate you get salt and water but you
also
oops
you also get co2 things have carbonates
you get carbon dioxide we're so in a
carbonate you get these but you also get
carbon dioxide I'll put up from that
little difference the rest is exactly
the same so let's try right in a
reaction for this one now I'm going to
use the 1 acid we need to know about
that we haven't looked at yet which is
hydrochloric acid we're going to react
it with a metal carbonate so why don't
we go for sink carbonate this time so
again each time it's just the name of a
metal and then whether it's a oxide
hydroxide or carbonate so this case is
Inc carbonate let's see what we get so
again I know that the name of my metal
is going to have to be as part of my
salt so I know we're going to have zinc
something right so if I bring this back
in this is what I need to learn whenever
I've got a hydrochloric acid I know I'm
going to form a chloride so as a result
I know that this salt is going to be
called zinc chloride I also need to add
in my water because whatever I have a
metal carbonate I form salt water but
then my final product I also produce
carbon dioxide so remember because I've
got a carbonate I also form carbon
dioxide so this is roughly how
neutralization works if you follow all
of those rules on those steps and if you
learn these important naming salts rules
you should be absolutely fine
in your example thank you